[Music]
Thomas Monday night reopening plans for
Canada's two biggest provinces Quebec
sets a date while Ontario has no
timeline we aren't going to reopen
everything at once what's planned to
resume and what's still off-limits
where's the support for Canadian seniors
the push for answers from the prime
minister can't catch a break and then
here comes this one from floods to fires
the new emergencies flaring up during
this pandemic top secret images captured
by US Navy pilots why the Pentagon is
releasing these now and what are those
mysterious flying objects
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the baby steps being taken
to reopen parts of the Canadian economy
after weeks of lockdown Canadians are
looking for some semblance of normal
life this is how Canada's public health
officer put it these past weeks have
made the words of millions of kids ring
true as they shout from the back seat
are we there yet no I'm sorry to saying
they're not quite yet Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau said again today things
will not get back to even close to life
as we knew it until there is a vaccine
or an effective treatment and he played
down the idea that people who have had
koban 19 might get immunity passports
there is no conclusive evidence right
now that having contracted kovat 19 once
protects you from contracting it again a
few months later this is too new a virus
scientists are working very hard on
exactly that whether the presence of
antibodies in someone will protect them
from from catching covered 19 again but
we don't know that yet Ontario's premier
laid out plans today to slowly
methodically begin to reopen some
businesses and public spaces it will
happen in three stages in Ontario each
will last two to four weeks and will be
closely monitored the first will involve
opening some workplaces and allowing
some small gatherings but there is no
timeframe the framework is about how
we're reopening not when we're reopening
no one wants the economy to open up more
than I do but we can't take anything for
granted
we can't take unnecessary risks Eric
Sorenson explains Ontario's framework
for the weeks and months ahead
Ontario says it'll be ready to open the
economy more widely the moment it's safe
Stage one will permit more businesses to
have curbside pickup and delivery
outdoor spaces like parks will ease
restrictions and hospitals will be able
to offer elective yet serious surgeries
that have been put off if all goes well
after two
for weeks bigger workplaces could open
with larger public gatherings allowed
but huge gatherings like concerts and
major sports events will remain out for
now and there is no timetable yet
progress doesn't mean we can quit now
and that's why I won't set hard dates
until we're ready Ontario will provide
guidelines for workplaces to be ready to
open this guidance will come as soon as
it's available so that employers can
start to make the plans that they need
to make the reason for some confidence
is the number of cases in Ontario has
leveled off during April an average of
460 new cases each day an increase but
not the doubling of cases we saw every
few days in March
what Ontario wants next is to see the
number of cases coming down in the weeks
ahead so it's safe to restart the
economy
the reason we're we're here where we're
at at this point of the flattening of
the curve is because of each and every
one of you we'll get there and we'll be
rolling that out as soon as we see the
consistency of the numbers dropping but
not too much covet 19 case numbers
appear to be coming down just a bit in
Ontario but any return to normal has to
protect the most vulnerable and it may
take us a couple weeks - one other
question mark for Ontario is schools
there are no plans to send any kids back
to class before the end of May leaving a
small window in June still as a
possibility
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto Quebec
is also making plans and it is setting
some target dates for reopening even
though it has the most cases and the
most deaths from Kovach 19 in Canada
primary schools and daycares in Quebec
will begin to reopen on May 11th though
attendance will not be mandatory and
high schools will remain closed until
September Mike Armstrong explains Quebec
strategy to phase that province back to
a new normal
with Quebec schools already shut down
for six weeks and Counting many of
argued to just leave them that way and
open up in the fall the problem with
that thinking the premier says is come
September we may be no further ahead
there's no proof that we'll have a
vaccine in six months so we'll be in the
same situation as today the plan is to
have students return to classes and
steps for now it'll only be daycares and
elementary schools for most of the
province classes will reopen May 11th
for the Montreal region where most of
the kovat 19 cases are it'll be May 19th
the goal is to keep classes to about 15
students and to ask them to keep two
meters of distance between each other
the situation will be monitored closely
if there are outbreaks students and
staff would be tested days on this
situation and the specific story that
class could be closed for 14 days now
the number of cases of kovat 19 is still
growing in Quebec the government says it
understands some parents will be nervous
sending kids back to school when it
feels like most of society is still shut
down while attendance will be optional
Cecily Ranger had hoped not to send her
daughter back to school until the fall
I'm not worried so much about her health
and we're worried that if the kids are
carriers that they're gonna get other
people the becks order of pediatricians
has pushed the province to reopen
schools it says children with
developmental delays or psychological
issues need contact with teachers also
according to experts children are less
likely than adults to contract kovat 19
and if they do much less likely to have
problems if we don't do it now we cannot
keep the kids inside forever now opening
schools comes as Quebec continues to
struggle with outbreaks and seniors
residences 400 soldiers hit the ground
this coming Wednesday to help with that
crisis but the province says the health
care system overall is doing well and
could cope if there's a problem Mike
Armstrong Global News Montreal here's
why Canada and other countries are
treading so carefully when it comes to
reopening the pandemic is still far from
under control today
it hit another grim milestone the number
of confirmed cases worldwide has now
surpassed 3 million more than 210
thousand people are known to have died
in Canada more than 1,600 new cases were
reported today a number of provinces
though did record no new cases today
Ontario Quebec and Alberta though are
still seeing big daily increases more
than 48,000 people in Canada have now
tested positive and more than 2,700
people are known to have died this was
the first day businesses could apply for
the Canada emergency wage subsidy and
roughly 30,000 businesses signed up in
the first few hours the subsidy covers
75% of wages for employers who have seen
a drop in revenues because of kovat 19
eligible companies can receive up to
eight hundred and forty seven dollars
per employee per week for up to 12 weeks
the benefit which is retroactive to
March 15th is designed to help
businesses rehire laid off workers and
keep people on the payroll
the Prime Minister is warning workers
they cannot dip into to federal
financial programs at once
if your employer can't hire you back if
you're a seasonal worker if you can't
find a job right now
the Canada emergency response benefit is
there for you and I want to remind
everyone you won't be able to keep both
the wage subsidy and the serve it's one
or the other not both the prime minister
says the money should start flowing May
7th but it could take longer for those
who don't have direct deposit set up we
know our elders are the most vulnerable
to kovat 19 more than half the deaths in
this country have occurred in long-term
care homes the federal government is
contributing 9 million dollars through
United Way to support services for
seniors but we've heard from some
seniors especially those on fixed
incomes who say it's not enough
our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson is looking into this Mercedes
the prime minister was pressed again
today about this What did he say well
Donna he's been asked about this a
number of times and the government
highlights the benefit that they have
provided that United Way money you
mentioned as well as a one-time GST
credit for seniors but many seniors out
there say that's not enough so we asked
the
Minister what more he has planned and
when it might come this is the answer we
got as I said we're looking at things
like supports for the most vulnerable
seniors who are seeing extra costs
because of kovat 19 and we will keep
working on that and have more to say
soon now Donna the concern is that a
number of seniors have seen their costs
increase things like getting groceries
delivered to them or having to take
taxis because they're vulnerable to this
bug and being on public transport could
be dangerous another big source of
increased expenses medications we spoke
with bill Van Gorder he is one senior
who has seen that happen in most cases
seniors are having to pay for extra
prescriptions because there's been a
limit of 30 days put on drug
prescriptions so that dispensing fees
have to be paid three times over a three
month period instead of just adjust once
Donna one point six million Canadian
seniors live on government programs
things like OAS the guaranteed income
supplement and CPP their income convene
hello is sixteen to twenty thousand
dollars a year so they are seen as
particularly vulnerable and we're
waiting to see if the government will do
more in particular for that group of
seniors okay Mercedes Stevenson and
Ottawa thanks there is talk of
quarantine fatigue in the US though it
remains the epicenter of the outbreak
the US has the most cases of kovat 19
and the most deaths yet as Jackson
prosecco explains one-third of states
are beginning to relax or even end stay
at home orders on the first day back in
Georgia business is not exactly booming
we're trying to stagger our clients and
not just load them in here so there's
not so many people in here one time
there are a few willing to risk it for a
haircut or a meal movie theaters can
reopen most are staying closed
there's no point when there are no new
releases I have 10 employees who are
relying on me in this theater for their
livelihood but I'm not gonna try and
make them choose between their
livelihood and their lives that's not
the case in parts of Texas where the
mayor of Colleyville allowed patios to
reopen over the weekend
there was a three-hour wait for a seat
there sanitizing there wiping down there
not giving anyone someone else's stuff
even hard-hit New York is considering a
plan to lift restrictions in rural areas
by mid-may health experts have warned
it's likely too much too soon
what happens if we dial back these
social distancing measures but then have
to dial it up again not one state has
met reopening guidelines laid out by the
Centers for Disease Control the number
of daily infections and deaths remain
stubbornly high and testing rates too
low and in fact there may be many waves
of infections the fear seems to be what
happens if the US doesn't at least try
to get back to business White House
economic advisors have warned the
unemployment rate could rise to levels
not seen since the Great Depression
Jackson Cross Co Global News Washington
there are new concerns emerging in the
UK about how Co bid 19 may affect some
children the NHS Britain's National
Health Service has issued an alert to
doctors warning there have been a small
number of cases of children presenting
with a multi-system inflammatory state
that requires intensive care the
symptoms can include fever abdominal
pain heart inflammation and skin rashes
some but not all of the children have
tested positive for kovat 19 it appears
to be a form of toxic shock syndrome
it's not clear if a Nuke ovid 19
syndrome is emerging in children in the
UK or if it's an as-yet unidentified
infectious pathogen having survived a
serious case of kovat 19 himself British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson was back at
work today
he'd been in intensive care and came
home from the hospital two weeks ago
Johnson today urged people not to lose
patience with the lockdown saying this
is a time of maximum risk but that the
UK is beginning to turn the tide he said
plans on how to ease restrictions will
be released in the coming days if this
virus were a physical assailant an
unexpected and invisible mugger which I
can tell you from personal experience it
is
then this is the moment when we have
begun together to wrestle it to the
floor
there is no widespread undetected
community transmission in New Zealand we
have won that battle but we must remain
vigilant if we're to keep it that way
that includes safely returning more New
Zealanders to work enabling more
businesses to reopen and allowing some
of the recreational activities we've
missed in the past four weeks that's New
Zealand's Prime Minister Jacinda ardour
and she imposed some of the strictest
lockdown measures of any country in late
March closing schools non-essential
workplaces and banning social gatherings
the country has just 1500 confirmed
cases and 19 deaths and there have been
only a handful of new cases in the past
few days so some restrictions on
non-essential businesses health care and
education are easing but physical
distancing continues and people must
remain in their social bubbles our durn
is considering expanding that bubble to
create a travel corridor with Australia
New Zealand's biggest tourism market the
rate of infection is slowing in
Australia too it has just over 6700
cases and 83 deaths Australia's
government was swift to close its
borders and beaches and ban cruise ships
Spain is taking another step to ease
some of it's strict to lockdown measures
children under 14 are getting their
first taste of freedom in six weeks and
police are using a drone to monitor
public spaces children have been granted
one hour of daily supervised outdoor
activity they must practice social
distancing and stay within one kilometer
of their homes it's been one week since
constable Heidi Stevenson died
coming up the campaign to honor the
mountie killed in the line of duty
there's so much information surrounding
coronavirus out there now we know you
have questions email your questions at
Global News Don CA tune in to global
national or go to global you see a slash
coronavirus now to find the answers
Nova Scotians are searching for ways to
heal after the murders of 22 people the
grieving period is being made even more
difficult because of physical distancing
and people are also looking for answers
from the complex investigation that's
underway
Ross Lorde reports now DS who responded
to the massacre and those serving in its
aftermath are not speaking publicly but
former frontline officers have no doubt
about what their colleagues experienced
28-year veteran Rob creaser has long
advocated for our CMP members creaser
agrees with calls for a public inquiry
to untangle the chaos using the
authority to call witnesses rather than
just the police during their
investigation they would be possibly
called to testify at a public inquiry
where their their statements would be
available for all the public to hear he
says there might never be an answer to
why the gunman massacred 22 people
dressed as a Mountie driving a fake RCMP
cruiser the Nova Scotia government is
considering outside reviews including a
closer look at why the RCMP relied on
Twitter messaging instead of issuing an
emergency alert trust is essential and
confidence in their ability to do their
jobs is absolutely essential as well as
victim's friends and families grieve
each day brings new ideas for honoring
those killed there's an online petition
calling for a Dartmouth high school
named after Prince Andrew to be renamed
in honor of Constable Heidi Stephenson
the 23 year veteran of the force and
mother of two is remembered as an
exemplary officer that she was killed
while trying to stop the gunman importa
pic where 13 of the victims were killed
Nova Scotia RCMP say they'll keep
control of crime scenes for several more
days other investigations are underway
the serious incident response team or
cert is examining part of the now DS
response including the discharge of
firearms involving two members that left
holes in a fire hall a location where
the gunman did not visit the director of
cert says there's no way of predicting
how long investigators will take to
follow the
reports because the agency has never
investigated anything like this
Ross lore Global News Halifax ahead
first a virus now floods and fires
in Fort McMurray Alberta floodwaters are
now forcing many people to abandon where
they live as Heather Urich's West
reports they're hoping another fierce
forest fire season isn't the next
emergency they'll face the streets of
Fort McMurray Alberta under water the
water from ice jammed rivers rose too
quickly for Joseph Vergara to get out of
town in his van they took me on the boat
and that's when I took the video and it
was just mind-blowing
next week Fort McMurray marks just four
years since a wildfire tore through this
community now it's dealing with assaults
it seems from all sides now we have to
try to find a new normal with this
coronavirus on top while that's
happening our oil prices have gone into
the negative and then here comes this
flood we can't control mother nature but
we can control our reaction to it we're
going to you know to respond to this
there are physical distancing measures
in place at evacuation centers anyone
without a place to go is being put up in
a hotel but with much of the city now
under a boil water advisory the local
government has asked the military for
help
we are aware of the flooding in Fort
McMurray and are looking right now very
urgently at ways that we can help spring
brings an increased risk of both floods
and wildfires pandemic or not definitely
is playing into our preparations for the
fire season and we've been working on a
number of initiatives because of travel
restrictions crews in BC and Alberta may
not be able to count on additional crews
flying in to help if the wildfire season
turns bad it's why both provinces are
doing all they can to prevent fires from
starting 60% of Alberta is under a total
fire ban and verga is now isolating in
another part of town with friends riding
out the latest crisis with hope that
like the fires of 2016 this too will
pass Heather your ex west Global News
Calgary
coronavirus zombies next the strange
tactic to keep people safe
well this is one way to get people to
stay home police in New Delhi are
dressing in helmets shaped like the
coronavirus and walking through the
streets India imposed a lockdown on its
1.3 billion people last month to stop
the spread of kovat 19 there are about
30,000 confirmed cases in that country
and in the middle of a pandemic why not
toss in some unidentified flying objects
the Pentagon has Declassified three
short Navy videos the official
description is unidentified aerial
phenomena US Navy pilots captured these
images in 2004 and 2015
they've been leaked before and one of
the pilots told reporters in 2017 that
he believed what he saw was not from
this world the Pentagon decided to
officially release them now to clear up
any misconceptions about whether the
footage is real so we know the videos
are real we just have no idea what those
objects are and that is global national
for this Monday I'm Donna Friesen thanks
for watching take care of yourselves bye
bye
[Music]